débat continuer pendant les informations
de midi pour tout vous dire sur ce sujet
tout fut la justice des relations police
justice et des réformes de la justice
l'autre gros dossier ces derniers jours
parce qu'on est en plein dans
l'actualité
jean philippe morel c'est bien sûr la
fronde des avocats quand on vous invitez
vous étiez en guerre contre la réforme
de l'aide juridictionnelle ou une
réforme on va dire du financement on va
essayer d'expliquer ce que c'est c'est
complexe
depuis vous avez gagné 16e taubira
reculé on n'est plus en guerre mais on
est en grève
le conseil national des barreaux s'est
prononcé hier pour une grève jusqu'à
mercredi car le problème de l'aide
juridictionnelle suprême qui va au delà
des seuls avocats c'est la question de
l'accès pour tous à la justice pour
simplifier ce débat on demande
aujourd'hui aux avocats de financer eux
mêmes
l'accès à la justice des plus démunis
c'est comme si on demandait aux médecins
de financer l'accès à la cmu pour la
santé pour tous pour l'expliquer aux
entrées saint-aubert elle veut qu'ils
aient plus de gens qui aient un accès à
la justice par l'aide juridictionnelle
et vous ce que vous contestez c'est le
financement de cette de cette
modification de la ddt d'assiettes en
mai dernier nombre de gens alors
effectivement il ya deux problèmes le
financement de l'aide juridictionnelle
qui ce qui était fait par un prélèvement
sur une caisse géré par les avocats qui
permet déjà de financer une bonne partie
de l'aide juridictionnelle d'ailleurs à
hauteur de 15 millions le là dessus
christiane taubira a fait machine
arrière et le deuxième aspect c'est que
on entend trouver des pistes pour
financer le budget de l'aide
juridictionnelle
nous on considère quand même
principalement que c'est un service
public l'accès justice qui vont être
financées par l'impôt
principalement parce que ces crèmes le
service public
éminent de l'accès à la justice qui
concerne l'accès d'ailleurs et justice
des personnes qui ont suivi mais aussi
victimes
1 parce que les victimes peuvent être
également les juridictionnelle est
important de le rappeler il s'agit pas
simplement de l'écurie sionnel pour les
délinquants ou les personnes qui
saisissent la justice il mais ça
concerne évidemment tout le monde est là
dessus on a effectivement une
incompréhension complète du garde des
sceaux qui s'est braqué qui a refusé d
alors le dialogue jeudi dernier à dijon
elle était présente et elle est venu en
catimini alors que nous l'attendions
avec les avocats du barreau de dijon
pour échanger
nous n'avons pas pu le faire nous
espérons effectivement rapidement qu'il
puisse y avoir une vraie concertation
pour repenser la justice de demain je
vais faire l'âne un peu pour avoir du
sens mais on sait que beaucoup d'avocats
ont des revenus très confortables on
sait qu'il ya des gros cabinet d'avocats
qui ne contribue pas du tout à l'aide
juridictionnelle
ce qui n'a pas une part normal dans
cette réforme il faut pas tout mais la
caricature vous avez le barreau de paris
effectivement qui a des cabinets très
florissant au barreau de paris vous avez
quand même un tiers des cabinets qui
sont en grande difficulté et moi là je
vous parle de de la justice de province
des avocats de province qui ont un
revenu moyen de 30000 euros par an
c'est-à-dire 2500 à 3000 euros par mois
qui sont pas ce sont des revenus certes
mais ce ne sont pas les bienvenus
d'autres professions du droit qui sont
bien mieux lotis sur le plan des revenus
donc faut pas tomber dans la caricature
les avocats de province participent
aussi à l'accès à la justice pour tous
par cite aussi à l'aménagement du
territoire
vous avez des avocats aegon vous en avez
à châtillon-sur-seine à semur en auxois
en côte d'or on participe aussi à une
justice de proximité et donc on veut pas
tomber dans la caricature de 2,2 de
certaines stars du barreau de paris qui
ne sont pas la réalité de la justice et
du du vécu des avocats c'est comme vous
savez les joueurs de ligue 1 et ceux qui
jouent en division d'honneur
dans le foot il ya quand même plusieurs
catégories de revenus vous vous réduisez
ça s'est longtemps meilleur il faut il
faut faire cette réforme il fallait
discuter plus quelle est votre position
clairement que vous connaissez très bien
mais c'est un monde que je connais bien
je pense qu'il fallait discuter plus je
moi je les annonces et d'ailleurs life
paix l'a repris
j'ai été satisfait de voir que
christiane taubira entendait six
revendications et renonçait à ce
dispositif
je pense qu'il faut qu'on sorte de la
crise très vite parce que c'est quand
même les la précarité qui s'installent
pour beaucoup ce sont les pauvres qui en
souffrent bien sûr beaucoup
donc il faut trouver une solution et on
a des solutions à proposer
bien sûr que la durée dictionnaire c'est
une politique de solidarité nationale
qui aide indispensable et qui doit être
certainement revu à la hausse parce que
vous avez de plus amples
deux personnes qui ne vend pas à la
justice parce que elles mais elles ont
un petit les ressources un peu
suffisante alors le mail trop trop
suffisante mais insuffisante
aussi pour leur permettre de bénéficier
de l'aide juridictionnelle l'idée était
d'agrandir d'aller toucher cette
formulation on le fait de façon quand
même très marginale dans la loi je pense
pas qu'on trouve la solution ici nous
nous l'avions fait dans la loi macron
donc qui a été votée et nous avons
décidé dans le cas de la loi ma cour de
mettre en place un fonds au 1er janvier
2016 un fonds interprofessionnel de
solidarité pour aider à la création de
maisons de pour l'accès au droit pour la
justice et aussi pour la durée
dictionnaire les masses et elle est
votée en juillet 2004 alors elle n'a pas
toute la partie juridique n'a pas été
retoquée au contraire elle a été
largement validées par le conseil
constitutionnel et j'en tire une
satisfaction extrêmement forte parce que
c'était des dossiers très très complexe
puisque nous étions sur les officiers
publics ministériels les charges etc
donc elle a été validée est sur le point
du fonds il n'est pas rejetée dans dans
ce qu'il représente simplement pour un
détail technique c'est qu'on a fait
l'erreur d'ajouter en précisant
l'assiette est le taux que cette eau est
cette assiette pouvait être modifiée par
voie d'arrêté ministériel
or ça ne peut pas être par voie d'arrêté
ministériel mais uniquement par le
législateur lovren ou un c'est que cette
mesure n'aura pas envie de vous entendre
ma constitution m cette mesure est
constitutionnel dès lors que la loi
savait qu'on s'était promis pas être
très technique
j'en suis pas dit tu vas te dis que
justement là il faut quand même pas dire
n'importe quoi
elle n'est pas à retoquer il s'agit
simplement de dire que cette loi que la
loi de fines
il faut que la loi de finances 2016
prennent en compte
simplement ce fonds on est dans les
pures de ce dispositif est pour la
discussion alors que c'est une piste
j'ai eu beaucoup d'avocats
j'ai même assisté à la
à la négociation qui a eu lieu à chalon
entre la conseillère de christiane
taubira et les avocats qui tous sont
tout à fait d'accord pour la mise en
place de ce fonds de solidarité qui il
faut bien le dire n'appelle pas une une
contribution très forte d d d d d
avocats mais beaucoup plus des autres
professions du droit que sont les
notaires des mandataires et les
huissiers de justice donc c'est une
piste au financement ce sera l'entrée on
a une piste pour le finance oui non mais
c'est la disposition va pas être
technique mais elle est aujourd'hui non
conforme à la constitution donc après il
faudra trouver effectivement des
solutions avec finances mme joly a pas
de solution de financement qui qui qui
s'affiche je reçois les noms des tueries
dictionnaire et la solidarité nationale
ça passe d'abord par le nouveau battait
pas pour que ce fonds se mettre en place
mais je vous dis pas ça devient alors
une agence de conseil constitutionnel le
conseil insurrectionnel donne une piste
la liste c'est d'inscrire dans la loi
fiscale
alors il faut donc aujourd'hui la voix
macron là dessus est effectivement vous
tentez de le faire passer par le web
finances mais bien ça mais c'est parce
que le bien c'est constitutionnel nous
dit cela ce n'est pas conforme
et vous connaissez la différence entre
un règlement et la loue à moi je relance
à discussion avec un ressenti il ya le
mouvement des médecins on a beaucoup
reproché au médecin en ce moment de pas
beaucoup parlé des patients dans tout le
mouvement pour du tiers payant
certains ont dit que d'un mouvement des
avocats les avocats parlait pas beaucoup
des justiciables non plus finalement
ce qu'on veut c'est sauver les
juridictionnelle c'est permettre aux
plus défavorisés aux plus démunis dans
le cas de la solidarité nationale de
pouvoir accès à la justice c'est la
justice pour tous et aujourd'hui ce
qu'on est en train de défaire c'est ce
droit d'accès à la justice pour tous
sens en ne rendant pas raisonnable le
financement de l'aide juridictionnelle
ça doit passer
principalement par l'impôt alors après
si une contribution aux droits de
mutation perçus principalement par les
notaires sont effectivement des pistes
qui sont pas effectivement
inintéressante mais aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas de solution trouvée l'heure qu'il
est on est on est dans le on est dans le
dialogue puisque si à une grève c'est
bien la preuve si le conseil national
des barreaux s'est mis en grève a appelé
tous les barreaux de france et quand
même sans précédent d'ailleurs on a fait
aussi le pouvoir politique et je le dis
quand même parce qu'on était le post
nationalité est scandalisé par ça et
beaucoup de téléspectateurs aussi
j'imagine que les forces de police sur
instructions du pouvoir politique ont
chargé devant les palais de jus
si ses avocats pour les réduire au
silence qui est tout à fait inacceptable
- ya des choses que je sais ce que ça
veut donc dire qu'il ya quand même une
réforme dans la loi macron qu'était une
piste pour travailler là dessus alors
que la garde des sceaux elle autres
ministres du gouvernement elle a proposé
une autre piste en parallèle est ce que
ça veut est-ce qu'on doit y lire quand
même politiquement une différence de
vues entre emmanuel macron et christiane
taubira en tout cas une défaillance en
matière de cohérence des dispositifs et
d'ailleurs mardi je serai dans le
cabinet de christiane taubira pour
rappeler cohérence que nous les
parlementaires
nous avions mis et l'anticipation que
nous avions mise par rapport à ce
problème de la durée dictionnaire mais
je voudrais dire une chose c'est que la
loi a été votée par les parlementaires
est ce fonds est instituée au 1er
janvier 2016 et je redis que le conseil
constitutionnel n'a pas retoquée ce
fonds mais a simplement demandé à ce
qu'on l'a inscrit dans la loi de
finances 2016 ce qui n'a pas été fait ce
que nous regrettons est ce que nous
demandons à ce qu'il soit fait en
nouvelle lecture alors il ya quand même
un problème c'est que ce fonds va être
créé mais il ya une montée en puissance
du fonds donc je pense que christiane
taubira au travers de la carpa et en
particulier de la carpa parisienne
imaginait un une contribution provisoire
en attendant que le fond monte en
puissance
voilà je pense son dispositif mais je
crois qu'il faut d'ores et déjà milité
et je pense que la majorité des avocats
je m'appelle assez souvent pour ce pour
cela milite pour que ce fonds se met en
place rapidement le timing ces grèves
des audiences mercredi et rencontre avec
la garde des sceaux marque un début mais
on y est on sent bien qu'ils aient une
guerre de tranchées entre macron et
madame taubira
on l'a bien vu pour la loi macron
puisqu'elle a été même taubira été
dépouillé de la mise en oeuvre de tout
ce qui touchait les dispositions
concernant les professions judiciaires
quand même principalement et madame
taubira aujourd'hui de reprendre la main
sur ce dossier c'est pas monsieur macro
effectivement c'est avec elle que vous
dénoncez c'est avec elle que nous
négocions
j'ai envie de pour terminer cette
émission d'aborder un point il nous
reste trois minutes mais on avait envie
d'en parler au début d'émission puis
finalement on est parti sur autre chose
au début d'émission parler d'un certain
nombre de réactions d' insulte sur les
réseaux sociaux pour la garde des sceaux
ait eu un point beaucoup plus politique
qui s'est passé la semaine dernière chez
nous en bourgogne
lorsque christiane taubira est venu à
chalon sur saône sûrs et de tribunal le
maire de chalon gilles platret n'a pas
souhaité l'accueillir chez vous aviez
envie d'en parler
cécile untermaier parce que ça a choqué
beaucoup de monde à droite comme à
gauche
ça peut même choqué d'ailleurs parmi les
forces de l'ordre enfin est-ce que de
votre point de vue à tous les trois vous
avez tous les trois de donner votre avis
est ce que c'est une bonne idée ce que
c'est dangereux pour la république pour
les institutions évidemment c'est très
dangereux et c'est vrai que quand on
évoque l'adjointe de talent on peut
imaginer que l avais un bon modèle avec
avec le maire de chalon sur saône qui va
au delà de son mandat il n'est pas
propriétaire de son mandat et là il fait
prévaloir une position personnelle
on ne respectant pas les institutions
moi je pense que on met en danger
gravement la démocratie et les valeurs
républicaines
quand on on ne satisfait pas à cette
exigence d'accueillir un ministre du
gouvernement
moi je n'ai jamais vu ça et je ne
l'imaginé pas je pense que c'est ça
mériterait presque une question sur une
révocation
on ne peut pas s'amuser avec les
institutions et on ne peut pas ensuite
pleurer en disant que finalement la
parole est libérée parce que là la
parole a été libéré on n'a pas le maire
ne s'est pas contenté de ne pas y aller
on aurait peut-être pu le comprendre et
encore mais il l'apprend clamé dans la
presse avec des propos qui sont à mon
sens pas tout à fait cette histoire est
pourtant oui je pense qu'on peut pas non
plus tomber dans la caricature et faire
un raccourci entre les propos de lélio
sur dalle en effet pas et ce monsieur
platret oui non mais j'ai entendu un
instant à parallèle hasardeuse bombes
ennemies nice vient effectivement
l'accueil je crois que c'est l'usagé la
pratique républicaine
clin d'oeil quand même c'est qu'on
inaugure un an je crois plus d'un an
après la fin des travaux du palais de
justice de paix de justice
ça peut être aussi une opération et une
visite électorale à deux mois des
élections régionales
la journée dans les forces de l'ordre 11
10 ben là dessus nous narguent arc et on
va dire un petit peu éloigné tout ça
puisque quelque part on est un peu
habitués à des sorties piste de genre de
la part de politiques de tous bords donc
après on va dire qu'on est dans une
position on va compter les points merci
fayard sauf le point merci à tous les
froides est venu débattre sur ce sujet
tout fut compliqué mais au coeur de
l'actualité ces derniers jours
merci chez vous de nous suivre avec
fidélité rendez vous samedi prochain sur
ce même plateau même heure même endroit
pour un nouveau débat de la voie est
libre
bon week-end à tous au revoir et merci